hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I mention a
question from one of my newsletter
readers Momo sahni who wrote in saying
dear Evan with respect could you please
share with me how you manage your 24
hours between reading researching
writings client needs visitation
sleeping and eating I would sincerely be
grateful should this enquiry meet your
kindness and speedy response remains in
sealy and respectfully your loving fan
thank you this is a great question and I
think time managing is one of the
biggest challenge is a lot of
entrepreneurs face because we're trying
to do too many things right you're
always short staffed you don't have
enough resources and so you have to be
creative and manage your time really
really really effectively now I've
created an entire worksheet series on
this that if you want you can go step by
step to help you manage your time but
kind of a quick high level overview of
what I do first thing is eliminate all
the things that are not essential so you
got to look at everything that you do in
your day and see do they really add
value to your business or not then you
try to automate as much as you can
through computer program software your
own algorithms and then you try to
delegate as much as possible what's left
over so you're focusing on what you
bring the highest value to every day and
one of the things that I think about my
way to work is what can I do today that
brings the highest value to my business
and if I find myself doing the same
things either repeatedly then I'll try
to find a way to automate it or things
that I really shouldn't be doing it's
important for my business to do but it
shouldn't be me then I'll delegate that
away for somebody else to do so I can
focus in on the things that I add the
most value to my business on and that's
it that's a constant battle because they
always chasing new opportunities looking
for new ways to grow and so I'm
constantly pacing that myself even as I
grow my business which is about how I
spend my day I'm a big believer in
Chungking your time and I think a lot of
people get distracted and I was to buy
new things coming in emails tweets
Facebook updates and you spend so much
time reacting to these things and
putting out fires that you don't
actually get into spend any time with I
call CEO time or you're building your
business and working on it instead of in
it so I like chunky
time and basically that that concept is
finding things that you do on a regular
basis and doing them all at once so if
you do something multiple times a day
like check email for example then do
that once a day if you do things
multiple times a week like maybe meet
people then try to do that once a week
and if you do things holding four times
per month then try to do it once a month
and try to apply that to your business
because you get in the zone a little bit
to say I'm on Sam checking email and an
email comes in if I'm working on
something else and I then check my email
it takes me another you know 15 minutes
to get back into what I was doing before
or long ways it's a big distraction or
if you can just go through all your mail
email all at once you're in that mode
you're entering things quickly you're
ready to go on to the next one you're
not being distracted by anything else
and you become a lot more productive so
you can get a lot more done in less time
by focusing your energies on one thing
and one task at a time so my typical day
I'm usually breaking my day down into
three one and a half hour chunks and I
find that one and a half hours is enough
time for me to kind of get something
completely done work really hard and
then take a break because after that my
brain starts to fry a little bit so I'll
break my day in two three one and a half
hour chunks usually from Monday to
Thursday that's what I'll be in the
office and then one of those trunks will
be email so email everything related to
email so if I need to answer the email
log of C but also look at the proposal
or get back to staff members or whatever
it is anything related to email is one
and a half hours per day Monday the
Thursday and I find that really helpful
because it forces me to focus you know
you only have an hour and a half you got
to get it done when you have that fixed
timeline you know you have to actually
you know buckle down get the word not
get distracted by anything else and when
it does is that this whole system allows
you to free up extra time to their do
more work if you want to or also have a
better work-life balance and go out and
do other things that can help you grow
personally professionally so my one and
a half hours email Monday to Thursday
then from there
each day's looks a little bit different
at least for me my monday is usually my
big work day so I try to get everything
done as much as I can for the week on
Monday so you know I may not get to all
the emails that come in on Monday if I
don't have time that one and a half
hours because I haven't checked since
thursday afternoon but then I'm doing
all sorry cough attack if I have client
work or things that are done that are
due during the week creating my
newsletter creating a blog post all that
is done on monday as much as possible so
i'll use the 21 and a half hour chunks
that are remaining on Monday to do that
I try to get everything done as much as
I can so I have the rest of the week to
focus on things i want to focus on
tuesdays usually want to call my CEO day
and so that's when I work on projects
that are undefined so every month is
something different I'm working on
things that I'm trying to use to grow my
business and as much as fall so you want
to make sure you have CEO time built
into every week so that you have time to
focus on the growth part right so you're
not just putting out fires and reacting
but you're able to grow your business on
Wednesday it's my video day so this is
Wednesday i'm filming all my videos i
look at everything that's been that's
come in for the past week and I usually
write back to people say i'll create a
video reply to you and i'll let you know
when it comes up and so on wednesday i
stay at home and i create my videos and
then I send them up to my editor who put
all the visuals and music and all that
fancy stuff in and so that's what i do
on wednesdays and then Thursday is my
meeting day and on Thursdays I'll have
calls and meetings and basically get in
the zone for that is usually at my
office or I call people and I set
everything up kind of back to back for
one day to do that and then friday is
usually off or I'm you know writing my
worksheets or you know don't check don't
check email don't book anything off and
then Friday excited Saturday Sundays off
for the weekend so that's kind of my
typical week and why I find it really
helpful to check your time so say our
meeting for example if you're doing
phone calls or you're meeting people
there's always a little bit of prep time
in advance right like the 15 minutes or
20 minutes before meeting or before
phone call you should is not very
productive right if you know you have a
meet
coming up or especially if somebody's
late on a phone call you can't really
get anything really productive done in
that time because you're thinking about
what's coming up so you can't really do
anything high-level just before that and
often just after that you get ideas that
come from the meeting and so you can't
really focus on anything else afterwards
as well and so I find if you have too
many meetings spread over over various
days you just spent that time in
meetings around phone calls and not
spending time growing your business so I
find that I book the meetings back to
back to back to back we're phone calls
as well and i find that gets me in the
zone so i wake up on thursday i know i'm
gonna have lots of meetings today that's
my meeting day you know have a shower
get changed you know dress up you're
ready to go and basically being the
mindset of going out and talking to
people being friendly outgoing and and
that's my mindset for the day and then
after Thursday I kind of decompress take
all the information and figure what my
next steps are going to be with all the
people that I met we're on a day like
Monday it's my min day to my get
everything done that I need to get done
for the week day I find that it's a
different mindset right I don't have to
worry about going out and talking to
people I'm more introverted on a monday
because i just have to buckle down and
work you know i don't have to dress up
if i don't want to don't have to shave
if i don't want to and so having those
different days i find really helps get
me in the zone for each particular task
and allows me to be a lot more
productive i get a lot more done in that
time in those you know three one and a
half hour chunks a day than i did before
during regular nine-to-five or plus work
hours so it frees up more time that you
can then use if you want to add another
chunk or to do your kind of personal
life stuff as well so hopefully that
helps maybe too much information in the
video i don't know hopefully you guys
liked it the worksheets explain a lot
more but i wanted to try to give you as
much info as I could through the video
it's a great question something I'm
really passionate about is trying to
improve your productivity so if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it makes fun to do more of
these duties for you and you have a
question about my schedule or about this
video or a different question about your
business but for leave in the comments
below I always read those i always reply
so thank you and I'll see you in the
next episode
you